[Musique]
alors bonjour à tous je m'appelle
Mathias et je suis passionné comme vous
le savez sans doute de musique de chant
de théâtre d'écriture de littérature
évidemment j'ai un bac + 5 en lettres
modernes et si je suis venu ici c'est
pour vous raconter raconter mon parcours
on parcours de vie mon parcourt aussi
artistique donc voilà alors
j'ai parlé de mes passions un petit peu
mais je dois vous raconter aussi autre
chose je suis une personne unique et
j'aimerais à partir de mon speech vous
montrer que vous aussi vous l'êtes
je suis une personne unique et pourtant
j'ai un frère jumeau
et il est né deux minutes avant moi
alors
ce qui est assez marrant quand on a un
frère jumeau c'est que les gens pensent
que c'est un ami pour la vie que c'est
l'amour parfait et bien il y a des hauts
mais il y a aussi des bas alors mes
premiers souvenirs de lui de mon frère
jumeau c'est lorsqu'on s'est changé nos
vêtements et ça faisait rire nos parents
qui se rendaient compte qu'on avait
changé nos vêtements c'est incroyable
mais je me souviens aussi d'autres
choses un petit souvenir que que j'ai un
peu oublié
quand j'étais petit j'étais une personne
très dynamique
je bougeais tout le temps je chantais
tout le temps je dansais tout le temps
j'adorais danser et à un moment donné
mon frère jumeau quand on était petit
Maddie que ça le gênait que je me
mettais à danser
à ce moment-là j'ai ressenti une forme
de honte la honte qu'il ressent
lorsqu'il m'a vu danser et à ce
moment-là j'ai enfoui en moi cette
passion qui aurait pu naître du coup je
suis resté certes un peu dynamique mais
j'ai perdu un peu de cette flamme
j'étais piégé dans le regard de mon
frère jumeau et dès que j'ai été petit
alors j'ai eu beaucoup de chance quand
même parce que de la maternelle jusqu'au
CM2 nous étions mon frère jumeau et moi
dans des classes différentes donc j'ai
grandi un petit peu différemment de lui
j'ai découvert des tas de choses quand
j'étais petit j'ai eu plusieurs
expériences par exemple quand j'étais au
CE2 j'ai pris pour passion le chant
parce qu'à un moment donné je rêvais
dans la dans la classe et mon professeur
m'a demandé de chanter devant tout le
monde parce que j'écoutais pas j'ai
chanté j'ai aimé ça les gens les
camarades de classe m'ont applaudi m'ont
félicité et c'est comme ça que j'ai eu
le déclic
en CE1 en CM1 désolé j'ai j'ai fait du
théâtre et j'écrivais des poèmes et là
c'est encore des passions qui commencent
à
émerger comme ça après je ne sais pas
trop quelle est la comment dire la
situation de mon frère jumeau qu'est-ce
qu'il a vécu au CE2 au CM1 quand a-t-il
eu un déclic pour ses passions à lui
mais moi ce que je sais c'est qu'on a
une sensibilité qui reste assez
différente bien qu'elle soit presque
identique par exemple
quand j'étais petit j'avais une passion
une période pour le Roi Lion j'étais
fasciné par le film par ses couleurs par
sa musique par ses chansons par
l'histoire mais à un moment donné mon
frère jumeau m'avait dit qu'il n'a
jamais été qui n'a jamais eu de période
Roi Lion
certes il l'avait déjà vu le film il a
il connaissait les chansons et tout mais
il n'avait pas il n'avait pas cette
passion pour ce film et ça m'a un peu
surpris je me suis dit que finalement on
se ressemble beaucoup mais on a quand
même des petites nuances quoi des des
différences finalement
donc de la maternelle jusqu'au CM2 je me
suis senti comme une personne très libre
comme une personne comment dire
originale une personne
une personne tout simplement mais au
collège les choses ont un peu changé le
collège c'est l'âge ingrat
et quand j'étais au collège de la
sixième jusqu'en seconde et bien j'étais
avec mon frère jumeau dans la même
classe
et les gens au départ il y avait des
regards ça nous dérangeait pas tant que
ça il y avait des questions c'était
intéressant les gens nous kiffaient rien
que par le fait que nous étions jumeaux
mais les choses ont un peu dérapées
j'étais une personne solitaire sauvage
je ne voulais parler à personne parce
que ces personnes là ont paru un peu
idiot tout simplement parce que en fait
il faisait un amalgame mon frère jumeau
voulait créer le lien avec eux par le
biais de l'humour mais il n'était pas du
tout réceptif il ne le supportait plus
même et du coup quand mon frère jumeau
faisait une bêtise j'ai payé les pots
cassées moi aussi on me prenait pour lui
et puis en même temps comme je suis
devenu une personne sauvage et bien
forcément on ne me supportait plus non
plus à cause de ça
je filais donc un mauvais coton et j'ai
reçu pas mal de brimades ça a été un peu
difficile pour moi
et donc j'ai enfoui un peu mes passions
j'ai enfui tout ce que j'étais j'étais
une personne dynamique j'étais et là au
collège je suis devenu comme un légume
je n'avais pas de très bonne note et
pourtant me prenait pour un intello
c'est assez bizarre parce que mon frère
jumeau était plutôt doué en classe moi
aussi je l'étais mais pas assez pas
comme lui
et puis ce qui m'a changé c'était les
scènes ouvertes au collège il y avait
toujours des scènes ouvertes où on
pouvait chanter danser jouer la comédie
et je voulais y aller à ces scènes
ouvertes parce qu'au final je n'avais
rien à perdre j'avais déjà tout perdu
j'avais pas d'amis j'avais pas d'allier
les professeurs m'aimaient bien mais
quand même j'avais tout perdu du coup je
me suis dit je vais chanter je vais
foncer je n'ai rien à perdre
et j'ai bien fait parce que ça c'est
tellement bien passé j'ai chanté avec le
coeur je ne voulais pas enfuir cette
passion qui était le chant la musique
donc j'ai chanté et mes camarades de
classe ont fini par m'apprécier ils ont
apprécié le fait que je sois passionné
par ça ils ont apprécié ma voix ma ma
comment dire ma manière de chanter aussi
mon assurance parce que le change les
fait j'ai aussi fait de la musique quand
j'étais gamin du coup j'ai fait des
chorales etc et j'avais un peu
d'assurance et du coup j'ai commencé à
devenir le jumeau gentil et mon frère
jumeau le jumeau méchant et je ne
supportais pas le manichéisme et
heureusement quand on a été en seconde
un professeur nous a demandé nous a dit
que gentille et méchant c'était vraiment
des mots de bébé quoi
donc voilà je suis devenu ça m'a donné
beaucoup de confiance en moi j'ai lâché
prise en fait en chantant je lâche prise
et c'est en lâchant prise que je me suis
rendu compte qu'il faut aussi que je
fasse ça auprès des autres il faut que
j'arrête de me prendre la tête et que
j'apprenne à vivre tout simplement
donc de la première jusqu'en terminale
j'ai fait un bac L j'ai eu un mention
Bien 15 de moyenne pile ce qui résume
très bien mon année j'étais ni très bon
ni trop mauvais j'étais bien donc 15 de
moyenne pile
arrivait à l'université j'ai commencé à
devenir une meilleure version de
moi-même j'ai encore fait du chant à
l'université j'ai fait du théâtre j'ai
fait de l'impro c'est incroyable de
faire de l'impro j'ai rencontré des gens
incroyables aussi qui m'ont appris à
devenir une meilleure personne et en
allant université j'ai fait un une
licence de l'être moderne je suis allé
jusqu'au bac + 5 j'ai fait un mémoire
sur les guerriers fauves des personnages
issus de la mythologie scandinave encore
une fois je joue encore dans
l'originalité dans la singularité
mais mes petits démons ont commencé à
resurgir en fait j'ai ressenti c'est
comme si j'avais eu un traumatisme par
rapport à ce qui s'est passé au collège
et au lycée ça c'est mauvais souvenir
poussait comme de la mauvaise herbe et
je me suis rendu compte que c'était pas
encore fini mais il fallait encore une
fois mais en fait cette histoire là ces
problèmes que j'ai eu par rapport à ma
santé mentale bien je me suis rendu
compte que c'était très familier par
rapport à ce que j'ai vécu au collège et
au lycée et il fallait que je fasse la
même chose pour pour en guérir il faut
que j'en parle d'ailleurs j'en ai parlé
à mon psychologue j'en ai pas j'en parle
à vous et j'imagine qu'après ça il va se
passer d'autre chose incroyable et
il fallait que j'en parle il fallait
aussi que je lâche prise encore une fois
il fallait que je sorte de ma zone de
confort parce qu'en chantant et en
commençant à écrire des chansons je me
suis dit qu'il fallait pour ne pas se
sentir paralysé il fallait que je sorte
de ma zone de confort que j'écrive des
choses qui me correspondent encore plus
que je me surprenne encore et c'est à
partir de là que on devient une
meilleure version de soi-même donc comme
vous le savez à l'université j'ai eu un
bac + 5 de 18 ans 2018 ans jusqu'à
aujourd'hui je vis ma meilleure vie je
vis les meilleurs années de ma vie ce
qui est incroyable et je pars du
principe que tout ce que j'ai vécu au
collège et au lycée et bien au final ce
n'est que partie remise
donc
ce que vous vivez au collège et au lycée
le passé n'oubliez pas que ce n'est que
partie remise et aujourd'hui j'ai envie
de cultiver encore ma singularité mon
originalité avec mon frère jumeau on
s'entend très bien du collège jusqu'au
lycée il y a eu une certaine omerta on
n'osait pas raconter nos problèmes mais
là aujourd'hui c'est différent nous
avons presque les mêmes passions il a le
cinéma moi j'aime bien le cinéma il nous
arrive d'aller au cinéma ensemble
d'ailleurs hier pas plus tard qu'hier on
a regardé le nouveau film de West
Anderson astéroïde City et sinon il aime
bien aussi je l'ai entraîné au théâtre
aussi on a fait une pièce tous les deux
avec d'autres personnes on a joué sur le
fait qu'on était jumeau c'était hyper
amusant
et donc ce qui me différencie de lui
c'est que moi j'écris des chansons et je
chante sachant que lui il joue de la
flûte traversière mais il a un peu
laissé de côté cette passion là et tout
ce que j'ai envie de vous dire c'est
cultiver votre singularité d'ailleurs
j'ai une surprise pour vous
j'ai apporté mon ukulélé et j'ai envie
de vous partager ce que je fais en vous
chantant une de mes compositions qui
s'intitule petit éloge du temps
poursuivre les traces de Marseille j'ai
du vendre ma montre et me voilà enfin
sur la cour je vais lancer mes filets je
suis la collection des madeleines de
course
pomme capitaine j'ai eu vos histoires
tranches de vie et combat
[Musique]
pour faire des retours en arrière faut
aller de l'avant afin d'y voir plus
clair dans son propre prison et le corps
se souvient lieu de ceux qui lui
manquent et l'Esprit nous retient nos
attirer nous capitaine
toi les caprices fantômes
dans mon capitaine toutes mes mémoires
sont remplies de
cercueil car le temps j'aime le passé à
contre
tant combler le vide de mon
âme France guérir s'enfuir l'adolée sens
voter dans l'océan du temps la mémoire
raconte le
couple des souvenirs Satos
je bois la tasse et je me prends la
route sans perdre les temps
alors voilà merci beaucoup alors
n'oubliez pas que par rapport à mon
expérience mon frère jumeau c'est vrai
qu'on se ressemble en fait nous sommes
un paradoxe à nous de tout seul
c'est-à-dire que on se ressemble on se
ressemble pas parfois c'est l'un qui est
meilleur que l'autre etc on a accepté ce
paradoxe donc voilà on se ressemble mais
en même temps on est différent on est
singulièrement différent si vous voulez
et j'ai envie de vous dire que je suis
vous êtes nous sommes tous des personnes
uniques donc cultiver votre singularité
et faites en sorte qu'elle vous permette
de créer de très belles choses merci
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]